but i've always worked in a job i loved
i loved it when i i loved it just as
much when i well when it was a big deal
if i made a thousand bucks and
i urge you to work in jobs you love i
mean i think you're out of your mind if
you take keep taking jobs that you don't
like because you think it'll look good
on your resume i was with a fellow at
harvard the other day who was taking me
over to talk and he was 28 and he was
telling me what he'd done in life and
which was terrific and and then i said
what are you going to do next and he
said well
he said after i get out my
my
mba says i think maybe i've got to work
for a management consulting firm because
it'll look good on my resume
and i said wait a second you've been 28
you've been doing all these things i
mean you've got a resume that's 10 times
as good as anybody i've ever seen it
already i said you take another job you
don't like just i said isn't that a
little like saving up sex for your old
age you know i mean
there comes a time when you ought to
just start doing what you know yeah but
i you ought to take a job when you get
out here take a job you love don't take
a job that you know you think is going
to look good on your resume take a job
you love it you may change it later on
but you'll jump out of bed in the
morning